just over 1 year ago before having even
come up with a proper logo or really
understanding how crazy the internet
could be two guys named Mitch and Greg
sat in their basement and decided it
would be fun to make videos on the
internet showing how awesome science can
be one year later we've had the pleasure
of bringing nearly 1 million of you
along for the journey
week after week to say we've been
surprised by the support and interest is
an understatement
so we wanted to take a second and say
thank you to all of you from those of
you who have followed us since the early
days to those of you who are just
watching for the first time we love
science but the fact that so many of you
do too has made this channel so much
more special so in lieu of the major
million subscriber milestone coming up
we thought we'd do something a little
different a sort of behind the scenes of
ASAP science using your questions like
who the heck are we or are we really
just hands floating in an infinite white
space so fire away hit us with those
burning questions as a comment or video
response and we'll release the special
edition episode next month in the
meantime we're excited to announce that
we finally have t-shirts for those of
you who yearn to show the world your
love of science check out the links in
the description now you can be not only
smart on the inside but trendy and hip
on the outside
oh yeah and at the same time you'll be
helping to support our little corner of
the internet otherwise known as ASAP
science here's to another year and
another million awesome science friends